Justice League may have been released almost
two years ago back in November 2017, but there's
still plenty of mystique surrounding the film.
Director Zack Snyder suddenly left Justice
League in May 2017 as post-production was
about to start, deciding to stay home and
support his family after the death of his
daughter, Autumn.
Into the void stepped Avengers director Joss
Whedon to complete the film.
But according to those who worked on the movie,
he didn't exactly pick up where Snyder left
off, making drastic changes to the final product.
The theatrical version of Justice League resulted
in mixed reviews, but then came hope for DC
fans in the form of the newsflash that Snyder,
despite his departure from the film before
completion, still has his version of Justice
League.
That juicy little tidbit has had DC fans'
tongues wagging, eager to see what has been
dubbed "the Snyder Cut."
It's been a long time waiting for an update
on that cut, and while it seems increasingly
unlikely the cut will ever be released to
the public, there are some in higher circles
who have been lucky enough to lay eyes on
it.
Jason Momoa, who starred in Justice League
as the underwater superhero Aquaman, is one
of that very elite group.
To Momoa's Instagram followers, this is old
news, because the Aquaman star revealed back
in August that the "Snyder Cut" was, quote,
"ssssiiicccckkkkkk."
Earlier this month, Momoa was speaking to
MTV News' Josh Horowitz when he revealed maybe
a bit more than Warner Bros. executives will
be pleased with.
When Horowitz brought up a past comment Momoa
made about the Snyder Cut of Justice League
that being…
"F—- yeah, I need to see that."
Momoa dropped this bombshell:
"Yeah, absolutely.
But I have seen it, so…"
"You've seen —"
"I've seen the Snyder Cut."
Though Snyder left Justice League before post-production
started, Momoa seemed to hint that Snyder
may in fact have completed his original vision
for the film effects and all.
After Momoa revealed he's already seen the
Snyder Cut, Horowitz posed the question:
So what does that mean?
Because the effects aren't done.
You've seen his assemblage of footage and
alternate takes?"
Only for Momoa to quip back:
“Oh, you think he — Zack couldn't finish
it?"
The actor didn't let too much slip though,
following with a quick "next question!" when
Horowitz tried to get confirmation about whether
the Snyder Cut is fully edited.
Despite the secrecy surrounding the cut, Momoa
does feel that it's worth making it available
to the public.
Momoa's also hoping his statements don't get
him fired from Aquaman 2, the sequel to his
surprise smash-hit standalone from December
2018.
Let's recap: The final cut of Justice League
that was ultimately released to the public
in November 2017 wasn't very well received,
with fans saying they could clearly see where
one director's vision ended and the other's
began.
According to The Wrap, the incomplete look
of Justice League spurred an insider to give
it the unfortunate description of "a Frankenstein"
film.
Sources with knowledge of the production have
also revealed that approximately 30 minutes
of the released film was actually directed
by Whedon, replacing 30 minutes of filming
done by Snyder the first time around.
That doesn't include footage shot by Snyder
that Whedon edited into a completely different
context for the final product.
Whedon, who is known for his work in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, managed to disappoint
DC fans as he tried to incorporate misplaced
humor into an altogether darker universe.
Followers of the franchise are thrilled there's
another version of Justice League, and have
been calling desperately for it to be released.
The hashtag "ReleaseTheSnyderCut" has been
doing the rounds on social media with a petition
started as early as the film's release in
November 2017, and efforts only amped up after
Momoa confirmed its existence in October 2018.
Momoa's recent remarks to MTV News only add
fuel to this ever-burning fire… a fire which
has also been stoked by the likes of Justice
League cinematographer Fabian Wagner and Jesse
Eisenberg and Ray Fisher, the actors who portrayed
Lex Luthor and Cyborg respectively.
All three have stated that they'd like to
see the Snyder Cut released to the public.
Though Warner Bros. is remaining tight-lipped
at this stage about the Snyder Cut of Justice
League, the excitement surrounding it sure
isn't dying down.
With little details being leaked here and
there, the studio might one day be persuaded
to let the heroes loose as they were originally
intended.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.